aujourd'hui je voudrais vous parler de
quelqu'un d'unique de quelqu'un
d'incroyable de quelqu'un qui à sa
manière a marqué l'histoire et qui pour
certains est une véritable star
et bien cette personne c'est vous
il n'y a jamais eu quelqu'un comme vous
avant et il n'y aura jamais plus
quelqu'un comme vous après bon alors je
vous rassure moi non plus je ne savais
pas avant mais cette découverte a changé
ma vie
alors pour vous aider à y croire je vais
vous inviter à penser aux personnes que
vous aimez le plus au monde
vos parents vos grands parents vos amis
vos enfants votre amoureux penser à eux
vous vous rendez bien compte à quel
point ils sont uniques et irremplaçables
et bien sachez que s'ils le sont vous
l'êtes aussi
moi je pense à ma mère pierrette bojan
une femme incroyable une femme avec le
coeur sur la main et une vraie
aventurière dans l'âme après m'avoir
fait le plus beau cadeau celui de me
donner la vie elle m'a aussi donné le
sens que j'allais donner à cette vie
quand j'étais jeune
elle me répétait un conseil jennifer
fais ce que tu aimes dans la vie
jennifer fais ce que tu aimes dans la
vie son conseil prenait toute son
importance parce que je la voyais elle
malheureuse dans son métier je sais
qu'elle aurait voulu être archéologue ou
encore mille autres métiers qui aurait
pu lui rendre sa liberté mais elles
pensaient qu'elles n'avaient pas le
choix
comme c'est le cas pour de nombreuses
personnes et pourtant elle aurait pu
tout faire si seulement il avait pu se
voir comme moi je la voyais parce qu'on
nous dit que l'amour rend aveugle mais
c'est pas vrai du tout l'amour nous rend
la vue
alors jennifer fais ce que tu aimes dans
la vie ok alors c'est plus facile à dire
qu'à faire
alors j'ai cherché partout le mode
d'emploi pour faire ce que l'on aime
dans la vie je me suis dit on va bien
apprendre ça à l'école non c'est dans ce
genre là qu'on devra prendre ce genre de
choses alors j'ai cherché à travers mes
cours d'histoire de français de maths et
puis va comment dire mais j'ai pas
trouvé
alors j'ai cherché à travers différents
exemples autour de moi m'a alors soit
les personnes ne faisait pas ce qu'elle
est mais non plus je pense que vous en
connaissez certains soient leur talent
ou leur goût n'était pas les miens j'ai
alors regardé à travers différents
métiers j'ai tenté différents métiers
j'ai souvent démissionner j'ai même
tenté à travers la sécurité d'un beau
cdi me suis dit au final c'est peut-être
sa puissance qu'on a essayé de me faire
croire
c'est peut-être ça faire ce qu'on aime
c'est peut-être se sentir en sécurité et
chercher le sens le pourquoi mon grand
père m'avait toujours appris à regarder
le sens et le pourquoi des choses
alors je me disais là un cdi ok pour
quoi faire
ah oui pour faire ce que je n'aime pas
de manière indéterminée ou super
programme google ou alors peut-être
mettre de l'argent de côté pour que
peut-être un jour à ma retraite je
puisse me réalisés ou génial
ben non ça n'avait aucun sens alors j'ai
démissionné et finalement et bien j'ai
arrêté de regarder à l'extérieur et j'ai
tourné le miroir vers l'intérieur vers
moi et c'est là que j'ai commencé à y
apercevoir ce que j'aimais parce que
faire ce que j'aimais dans la vie ça
voulait en fait dire faire ce que
j'étais alors dans cette quête de moi
même je suis parti en asie avec mon amie
on a été en inde au népal en chine au
tibet et sur ce chemin on a interviewé
toutes les personnes rencontrées sur
notre chemin
je leur demandais et pour vous c'est
quoi l'amour c'est quoi le bonheur
qu'elle est vote pour que représente le
travail pour vous l'argent c'est quoi
vos rêves
qui êtes vous et c'est là que j'ai fait
cette grande découverte
c'est là que je me suis rendu compte
qu'on était tous uniques et qu'on avait
tous notre propre vérité sur le monde
que chacun annoncé comme étant la vérité
bien sûr donc c'était magique parce que
finalement vous voyez toutes ces
différences c'est finalement notre plus
beau point commun c'est magnifique
et alors que j'étais en inde
je quittais bénarès ma mère a eu un
accident sur paris elle est tombée dans
le coma et elle est décédée quelques
jours plus tard sa mort m'a énormément
énormément appris elle m'a rappelé à
quel point la vie est courte et fragile
et à quel point on ne peut fonder ses
espoirs sur un deux mâts hypothétique
qui n'arrivera peut-être jamais jennifer
fais ce que tu aimes dans la vie quels
conseils
la mort est un sujet tabou chez nous et
pourtant c'est elle qui nous rappelle
l'essentiel c'est elle qui nous rappelle
que le but de la vie mais c'est d'en
créer un
c'est de lui créer un sens là
aujourd'hui maintenant et moi c'est là
que cette graine d'entrepreneuses que
m'avait transmis mon père a germé et
c'est là que l'idée du projet monde qui
es tu es né ce que je voulais c'était
permettre à chaque être humain de se
rendre compte de sa valeur je voulais
qu'ils puissent exprimer ce qu il est et
je voulais qu'ils puissent transmettre
son empreinte de vie à ses enfants et
aux futures générations
ce projet il est né ici à l'île de la
réunion et c'est pas par hasard parce
qu'ici c'est une terre de métissage
exemplaires pour le monde une île dont
je suis tombée folle amoureuse il ya
maintenant six ans et une île qui a
permis à ce projet d'exister
je voulais mettre l'être humain au coeur
de la vocation et du fonctionnement de
ce projet c'est pourquoi chaque être
humain en est potentiellement le coeur
l'auteur l'acteur et le distributeur
en d'autres termes c'est un projet dit
de crohn making it crowd sourcing
ce qui veut dire qu'il est réalisé par
la commune
et qu'il appartient à la communauté
c'est à dire à vous tous à chacun
d'entre nous alors qu'est ce qu'on fait
tous ensemble qu'est ce qu'on doit faire
pour nos parents pour nos enfants
maintenant vous savez vous travaillez
avec 7 milliards d'autres individus et
que vous devrez pour le projet monde qui
es tu eh bien on écoute et on recueille
les empreintes de vie de nos proches de
nos amis de nos voisins ou même de cet
inconnu rencontré dans la rue on les
écoute l'orgueil avec enthousiasme et
bienveillance l'entousiasme ces deux
lots pour les personnes ensuite pour les
préserve on les préserve comme la chose
la plus précieuse au monde
et pour ça il ya une bibliothèque en
ligne monde qui es tu enfin on les
valorise
on les valorise chacun à notre manière
que ce soit justement avec de
l'enthousiasmé ou encore avec plein
d'autres idées que vous pourriez avoir
là aujourd'hui
nous par exemple on a fait des
biographies des livres même des
expositions interactives imaginé une
exposition dont vous faites tous partis
imaginez dire à votre grand-mère et
vient mamie on va les voir une
exposition dont tu fait partie
des milliers d'initiatives locales
réunis autour d'une vocation sociale
commune et autour d'une bibliothèque en
ligne commune
c'est ça monde qui es tu sur le long
terme nous souhaitons faire passer
l'être humain au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco
eh oui l'être humain au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco
vous vous imaginez quelle belle manière
de rendre hommage à ceux qu'on aime
quelle belle manière de rappeler à
chacun que sa vie compte qu'il a une
valeur qu'il est unique
pourquoi faire pour qu'ils la vivent
cette singularité
parce que quand on répond à cette
question monde qui es tu eh bien on peut
répondre à la question monde
que fais tu quand on regarde à
l'intérieur il est possible de faire ce
que l'on aime dans la vie ma vie m'a
prouvé que c'était possible
alors aujourd'hui je le transmets j'ai
fait des recherches et j'ai développé
une méthode qui invite l'individu à se
poser quatre questions
quatre questions fondamentales
auxquelles nous avons tous une réponse
unique
premièrement qui es tu quels sont vos
forces quelles sont vos talents qu'est
ce qui fait que vous êtes vous est pas
votre voisin qu'est ce qui fait que vous
êtes unique
deuxièmement que veux tu
quelle direction avez vous envie de
donner à votre vie quel sens
avez vous envie de lui donner
troisièmement que fais tu et oui quel
métier quels projets qu'elle
l'entreprise avez vous envie de créer
qui vous ressemble quels projets vous
permet d'offrir ce que vous êtes au
monde
et enfin comment le fait dessus parce
que bien sûr il faut agir pas par pas
pour se réaliser et réaliser nos rêves
aujourd'hui je travaille avec des jeunes
et des moins jeunes qui se cherche qui
cherche à savoir ce qu'ils veulent faire
dans la vie mais ce que je voudrais
c'est que demain on enseigne ça à
l'école qu'on sorte de l'école avec un
bac en poche
ok mais qu'on sorte aussi de l'école
avec une connaissance de nous mêmes
aujourd'hui si on me demande ce que je
fais dans la vie
eh bien je suis jennifer vigneault parce
que c'est ça notre vrai métier c'est
être nous-mêmes l'écosystème de
l'humanité c'est comme la nature ça a
besoin de diversité pour s'équilibrer
l'écosystème de l'humanité a besoin de
chacun de vous elle a besoin de vos
rêves de vos talents
alors osez être ce que vous êtes osé
exprimer ce que vous êtes aux effets
r ce que vous êtes osez être unique
merci
ce